[Applaudissements]
ce qu'il faut dire de
fadise pour voir enfin du fond de son
lit un soutien gorge sur une
chaise une paire de bas sur un
tapis nous les coureurs impénitents nous
les don juju nous les don
juant mais chaque fois que l'on
renifle la piste fraîche du
jupon pour un baiser pour une
gifle sans hésiter nous
repartons la main frôleuse et l'œil
luisant nous les don nous les
don
jant le seul problème qu'on se
pose c'est séparer en de
portion 55 kg de chair
rose de 55 g de
nylon c'est pas toujours un jeu d'enfant
pour un don J pour un don
juant le mannequin la
manucure
la dactyotesse de
l'air tout est bon pour notre
peature que le fruit soit M ou qu'il
soit
vert faut qu'on y croque le temps nousou
les
don mais il arrive que le cœur
s'accroche aux épines d'une jolie
fleur qu' N met dans sa poche sous son
mouchoir trempé de
pleur c'est le danger le plus fréquent
pouron j j
pouron
juant nous les gros cotes de de
taille nous les gros croqueurs de
souris il faut alors livr
bataille bien marcher vers la
mairie
au bras d'une belle maman pauvre don
juge pauvre non
juant nous t'amiserons les
lumières même quand la mort viendra
sonner et nous dirons notre
prière sur un chapelet de grain de
[Musique]
beauté en attendant dans le
jugement nous les don juju nous les
don
[Musique]
jant